This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。来自 1979 年，对那时的我来说是一个重大时刻。84 年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello and welcome back to the podcast to the show. Hope you've been amazing and you're feeling loved and motivated inspired by your. your life at the moment. I'm feeling great. But if not, well, maybe this episode can explain just an aspect of why that may not be the case. I'm guessing if you're listening to this, if you clicked on this,
在 i-Heart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 and learn the hard way。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。你好，欢迎再次来到这个播客节目。希望你们一直都棒极了，并且感受到你们生活中目前的爱、动力和启发。我感觉棒极了。如果不是的话，嗯，也许这一集可以解释为什么会这样的一些原因。我猜如果你在听这个，如果你点击了这个，
then this topic probably resonates for you in many ways. So let's not waste any more valuable time. I have a lot to discuss today, but I don't want to make another 50 minute episode like I did a couple weeks ago. I've realized recently, sorry, here I go rambling, not even a minute in, but I realize that listening to one of my episodes normally takes the same amount of time for me as it does to get to my local beach between 22 to 13 minutes. Hence why I'm trying to keep them more bite-sized. How sweet. Yes, I do listen to my own podcast in the car and yes, it's strictly for professional purposes and reasons because I don't always listen over them. when I press publish because I am lazy.
那么这个话题可能在很多方面都与你产生共鸣。所以我们不要再浪费宝贵的时间了。今天我要讨论的内容很多，但我不想像几周前那样再做一期 50 分钟的节目了。我最近意识到，抱歉，我又开始扯远了，甚至还没到一分钟，但我意识到听我的一集节目通常和我去当地海滩花费的时间差不多，大约在 22 到 13 分钟之间。因此我才试图让它们更精炼一些。多贴心啊。是的，我在车里确实听我自己的播客，而且是的，这完全是出于专业目的和原因，因为我并不总是在我。当我点击发布时会通听一遍，因为我很懒。
So I have to do my due diligence later on. Anyhow. Today we're talking about people pleasing, what it is, how to break the cycle, the trouble it gets us into, and why are you kind of getting in your own way by refusing to say no? This episode was inspired by many conversations with one of my bestest of friends, Aaron, and one of my most loyal listeners. Oh my gosh, I miss her so much. but shout out if you're listening, which you probably are.
所以我以后必须做好尽职调查。无论如何。今天我们来聊聊讨好型人格，什么是讨好型人格，如何打破这种循环，它给我们带来了什么麻烦，以及为什么你拒绝说“不”其实是在阻碍你自己的发展？这一集灵感来自于我和我最好的朋友之一艾伦（Aaron）进行的多次对话，她也是我最忠实的听众之一。哦天哪，我太想念她了。如果你在听的话，虽然你很可能在听，给你比个心。
I'll see you soon. But we chat about this a lot because I think it's a behavioral pattern we both fall into quite frequently. And it came up recently because she was up in Sydney for my birthday. And while she was here, I was talking about how I was like almost anxious because if I didn't enjoy myself, even if I didn't enjoy myself, sorry, I wanted everyone else to be having a really good time. I wanted them to be happy.
我很快就会见到你。但我们经常聊起这个，因为我认为这是我们俩都会经常陷入的行为模式。最近提起这个是因为她去了悉尼给我过生日。当她在这里的时候，我一直在说我几乎感到焦虑，因为如果我没有玩得开心，即使我没有玩得开心，抱歉，我希望其他所有人都能玩得真的很开心。我希望他们快乐。
And she said, Gemma, that's people pleasing to a tea. And here we are doing an episode on it. Strap in and get ready to learn. The idea of people pleasing has had a pretty steady rise in pop culture and psychology. Pop culture, I guess, these last few years. I think probably due to the increasingly individual nature, the trend or kind of perspective of psychology in its applications to our lives and the focus on self-growth and self-awareness. And the idea is also quite a recent one, the idea of People Pleas. obviously the behaviour has been around for a while we just haven't always um i guess
她说，杰玛，这就是典型的讨好型人格。于是我们就这一主题录制了一期节目。系好安全带，准备学习吧。在流行文化和心理学中，“讨好型人格”这个概念一直处于稳步上升的趋势。流行文化，我想，主要是在过去几年里。我想这可能是由于心理学在我们生活中的应用日益呈现出个人主义的特征，这种趋势或某种视角，以及对自我成长和自我意识的关注。这个概念也是相当近期的，即讨好型人格的概念。显然这种行为存在一段时间了，只是我们并不总是——呃，我猜
had a name for it but there have even been like poems written about it so one is pretty dramatic i found it when i was researching this episode and i thought it was quite funny wait let me read a line where is it i always say yes can never say no swallow or hurt let no feeling show he insulted me badly called me the son of a bore i just rolled over saying kick me, kick me more. Some very dramatic lines from that poet, Alan, Bruce Thompson. Thank you, thank you for your inspiring, if not depressing lyric, Alan. But I don't know why I said that, but I think it's just interesting. I don't know why I felt the need to cite this poem that I had in my research, but I think it's just an indicator of how long this behaviour has kind of been
给它起过名字。但甚至还有关于它的诗歌。其中有一首非常戏剧化，我在研究这一集时发现了它，我觉得它挺搞笑的。等等，让我读一句，在哪儿呢？我总是说好，从不拒绝。吞下伤害，不让任何情感表露。他狠狠地侮辱了我，叫我无趣之人的儿子。我只是翻了个身说，踢我，再用力踢我。来自诗人艾伦·布鲁斯·汤普森（Alan Bruce Thompson）的一些非常戏剧化的台词。谢谢你，谢谢你这首虽不沮丧但也算鼓舞人心的歌词，艾伦。不过我不知道我为什么这么说，但我觉得这很有意思。我不知道为什么我非要引用这首在我研究资料里的诗，但我觉得这只是一个标志，表明这种行为作为
part of a dialogue around our interactions with other people. And people pleasing has become Such a popular term though that it has, wait for it, its own webmd page. Yes, ladies and gentlemen, you know the site you go to check if your headache may be, I don't know, cancer, well that site can now diagnose you with people pleasing. It's also inspired numerous psychology books such as the disease to please and when it's never about you. Titles that are almost as dramatic as our friend Alan's poem, but you get the gist. People pleasing is now a pretty common. popular part of daily psychobabble. So what is people pleasing? Yes, it does kind of say it all
围绕我们与他人互动的对话的一部分，已经存在了多久。然而，“讨好型人格”这个词变得如此受欢迎，以至于它——等着瞧吧——拥有了自己的 Webmd 页面。是的，女士们先生们，你知道那个用来检查你的头痛是不是，我不知道，癌症的网站，嗯，那个网站现在可以诊断你是否有讨好型人格。它还启发了许多心理学书籍，例如《讨好之病》（The Disease to Please）和《当一切与你无关》（When It's Never About You）。这些书名几乎和我们朋友艾伦的诗一样戏剧化，但你明白那个意思。讨好型人格现在已经成为日常心理学黑话中非常普遍的一个部分。那么，什么是讨好型人格？是的，它确实
in the name, but let's dig a little deeper as we tend to do in this podcast. Essentially, people pleases are those who cannot maintain clear boundaries with others and do really whatever it takes essentially to make other people happy. They're often highly attuned to others and seen as agreeable, helpful, really kind. However, people pleases may have trouble advocating for themselves, which can lead to a pretty harmful pattern of self-sacrifice and self-neglect. I think whilst it's generally seen as a positive attribute to want to help others and act pro-socialally and in a way that kind of aligns with this entrenched altruistic norm, when we begin to see ourselves as second to the needs of others, you will inevitably end up
顾名思义，但让我们像在这个播客中经常做的那样，深入挖掘一点。本质上，讨好型人格是指那些无法与他人维持清晰界限，并且基本上不惜一切代价让其他人开心的人。他们通常对他人高度敏感，被视为随和、乐于助人、非常善良。然而，讨好型人格可能很难为自己发声，这可能会导致一种相当有害的自我牺牲和自我忽视的模式。我认为，虽然想要帮助他人并以亲社会的方式行事，以及以一种符合这种根深蒂固的利他主义规范的方式行事，通常被视为一种积极的品质，但当我们开始将自己置于他人需求之后时，你不可避免地会最终感到
depleted and anxious. And you also tend to experience disconnect with yourself and become unable to recognize or express what you need from a situation or from others in your lives. Like I've kind of said already, a key element of people pleasing is that it generally goes beyond simple kindness. It involves, you know, editing or altering words and behaviors for the sake of another person's feelings or reactions. And that was explained by Erica Myers. And she's a therapist in the US at the University of Oregon. This is what else she kind of had to say. You might go out of your way to do things for the people in your life based on what you assume, what you assume they want or need and you give up your time and energy to get them to like you, to get them to love you more.
精疲力竭且焦虑不安。而且你往往会体验到与自我的脱节，变得无法识别或表达你从某种情况或生活中的其他人那里需要什么。就像我刚才已经说过的，讨好型人格的一个关键要素是它通常超出了单纯的善良。正如美国俄勒冈大学的治疗师埃里卡·迈尔斯（Erica Myers）所解释的那样，它涉及，你知道的，为了另一个人的感受或反应而修改或改变言语和行为。这就是她要说的其他内容。你可能会不遗余力地为生活中的人们做事情，基于你的假设，即你假设他们想要什么或需要什么，你放弃了时间和精力来让他们喜欢你，让他们更爱你。
And Myers says that this is how people, people, people, blah blah, people pleasing. It's a bit of a tongue twister. How people pleasing can cause trouble. The urge to please others can be. damaging to ourselves and potentially to our relationships when we allow other people's wants to have more importance than our own needs and when we try to anticipate what others want from us without trusting that they can advocate for themselves. It's a pretty well-known rule of thumb that relationships they should be equal, give and take. I think that's the, I think the previous overview of people pleasing. It shouldn't be taken to mean that you can never offer a distance for others, because you might be placing your second. No, it's all about balance, baby.
迈尔斯说，这就是人们，人们，人们，吧啦吧啦，讨好型人格。这有点像个绕口令。讨好型人格是如何引起麻烦的。当我们允许别人的愿望比我们自己的需求更重要，以及当我们试图预测别人对我们的期望而不相信他们能够为自己发声时，取悦他人的冲动可能会对我们自己以及潜在的我们的关系造成破坏。这是一个广为人知的经验法则，即人际关系应该是平等的，有付出也有回报。我认为，我认为前面关于讨好型人格的概述。不应该被理解为意味着你永远不能为他人提供帮助，因为你可能会把自己放在第二位。不，这一切都是关于平衡的，宝贝。
What I find really interesting with people pleasing behaviours is how our brain literally hijacks itself to not only be better at recognising other people's needs over our own, but happy to do things for others at our own expense. It's so counterintuitive and counter to kind of an evolutionary idea of survival. So here are some pretty typical indicators of being a people pleaser, not just someone who's happy to help a friend, a partner, or, you know, a neighbor out, but a full-blown people plays up. So you have a difficult time saying no. You're preoccupied with what others might think of you, which we're going to talk about a lot
我发现讨好型人格行为中最有趣的是，我们的大脑是如何字面意义上地“劫持”自身的，它不仅更擅长识别别人的需求而不是我们自己的需求，而且还乐意以牺牲我们自己的利益为代价为别人做事。这太违反直觉了，也违背了某种进化的生存理念。所以这里有一些典型的讨好型人格的指标，不仅仅是一个乐于帮助朋友、伴侣或邻居的人，而是一个成熟的讨好型人格者。所以你很难说“不”。你全神贯注于别人对你的看法，我们稍后会对此进行很多讨论。
later on. You feel guilty when you have to tell people no. You fear that turning people down will make them think that you are selfish. You agree to things that you don't like or do things that you don't want to do. This is really common with some of my friends, you know, they sign up for things or they offer to help a friend out and they just really need, you know, some alone time. It's not what they need to go and socialize more. You might struggle with feelings of low self-esteem. You want people to like you and you feel that doing things for them will in some ways earn their approval. You're always
当你不得不对别人说“不”时，你会感到内疚。你害怕拒绝别人会让他们觉得你自私。你答应自己不喜欢的事情，或者做你不想做的事情。这在我的朋友中真的很常见，你知道的，他们报名参加一些活动，或者他们主动提出帮助朋友，而他们其实非常需要，你知道的，一些独处时间。他们需要的不是去进行更多的社交活动。你可能一直在与自卑感作斗争。你希望别人喜欢你，并且你觉得为他们做事情在某种程度上会赢得他们的认可。你总是
telling people sorry and you're taking blame for things even when it isn't your fault. And think about what kind of life that would entail if you're constantly apologizing for things, always in the guilt trap our brains have created or being so preoccupy. occupied with what others think that you can't really ever seem to consider yourself. And it's no surprise that psychologists and researchers have found heaps of known links between people pleasing and disorders like social anxiety, OCD and depression. So where does this type of behavior come from? I want to jump into some very interesting links later on, mainly around trauma and gender.
对人们说对不起，即使不是你的错，你也把责任揽在自己身上。想想看，如果你不断地为事情道歉，总是处于我们大脑创造的内疚陷阱中，或者全神贯注于。专注于别人的想法，以至于你似乎永远无法考虑你自己，那么这样的人生将意味着什么。因此，心理学家和研究人员发现讨好型人格与社交焦虑、强迫症和抑郁症等疾病之间存在大量已知联系，这也就不足为奇了。那么这种行为究竟从何而来呢？我稍后想探讨一些非常有趣的联系，主要围绕创伤和性别。
But before then, let's talk about some of the more typical causes of. of people pleasing behavior. So firstly, and we've talked about this in some of the indicators, but poor self-esteem. So sometimes people engage in people pleasing behavior because they don't value their own desires and needs. Perhaps due to a lack of self-confidence, people pleasers have a need for external validation
但在那之前，让我们先来谈谈讨好型人格行为的一些更典型的成因。首先，我们已经在一些指标中讨论过了，但那就是糟糕的自尊心。所以有时人们会表现出讨好型人格的行为，是因为他们不珍视自己的愿望和需求。也许由于缺乏自信，讨好型人格者需要外部认可，
and they may feel that doing things for others will lead to approval and acceptance. People pleasing behavior is not always an expression of goodwill. It comes from a longing to feel socially secure, and it's a symptom of a generalized fear of abandonment, which usually comes from the relationships we have with our parents or our caregivers, and a general sense of self-esteem. So this other idea in psychology called self-efficacy. So self-esteem and self-efficacy.
他们可能会觉得为别人做事情会带来认可和接受。讨好型人格行为并不总是善意的表达。它源于对获得社会安全感的渴望，并且是对普遍存在的被遗弃恐惧的一种症状，这种恐惧通常源于我们与父母或照顾者的关系以及对自我价值的总体感觉。所以心理学中的另一个概念叫做自我效能感。所以是自尊心和自我效能感。
Self-efficacy, it refers to an individual's belief in their capacity to execute behaviors necessary to produce specific performance attainments. So basically, it kind of reflects your confidence in your ability to exert control over your own motivations, your social environment, and the health of your relationship. So what's really interesting about self-efficacy is that researchers haven't yet been able to determine the direction of that relationship. So whether low or high self-efficacy contributes to people-pleasing tendencies more. So on one hand, if you feel, feel like you do have a lot of control over the quality of your relationships, you may be more likely to engage in people pleasing behaviours because that's one of your tactics for control.
自我效能感，它指的是个人对自身能够执行产生特定绩效结果所需的行为能力的信念。所以基本上，它在某种程度上反映了你对自己控制自己的动机、社会环境以及人际关系健康状况的能力的自信。所以关于自我效能感，非常有趣的是，研究人员尚未能够确定这种关系的因果方向。也就是说，究竟是低还是高自我效能感对讨好型人格倾向的贡献更大。一方面，如果你觉得，觉得你对人际关系质量有很大的控制权，你可能更有可能参与讨好型人格行为，因为那是你控制的策略之一。
But in contrast, feeling like you don't have a lot of control may lead you to overcompensate and try to constantly help others. If anyone has the answers to that conundrum, the link between self-efficacy and people-pleasing behaviours, please let the psychological community know. They'd be very interested. perfectionism is another huge, huge determining factor of people-pleasing. We've talked about this many times before on the podcast. It comes up all the time. But sometimes people want everything to be just so,
但相比之下，觉得自己没有太多控制权可能会导致你过度补偿，并试图不断地帮助他人。如果任何人对这个谜题有答案，即自我效能感与讨好型人格行为之间的联系，请告知心理学界。他们会非常感兴趣的。完美主义是讨好型人格的另一个巨大、巨大的决定因素。我们以前在播客中多次讨论过这一点。它一直都在出现。但有时人们希望一切都恰到好处，
including how other people think and feel about them. Helping others, prioritizing them, makes you seem more likable and keeps those people in your life. And this gives the perception of a perfect social circle and I guess a perfect lie. And people pleading and perfectionism, they both come from the ego. So for those who aren't so familiar with this Freudian idea of the ego, which is different from our normal conception of the ego as like the arrogant part of ourselves,
包括别人如何看待和感受他们。帮助他人，优先考虑他们，会让你显得更讨人喜欢，并让这些人留在你的生活中。这给人一种完美的社交圈的印象，我想也是一种完美的生活。讨好和完美主义，它们都源于自我。所以对于那些不太熟悉弗洛伊德的自我（ego）概念的人来说，这与我们通常认为的自我作为我们身上傲慢部分的观念不同，
let me explain. So according to Freudian theory, there are three core elements of the human psyche. The id, the ego and the super ego. So the ego is who we are in the present. It's the reality created by the behaviors that we express. And the super ego and the id, they're kind of like the devil and the angel on your shoulder. The super ego represents pure morality and what society would expect us to do. And the super ego is part of the unconscious mind or the psyche that is kind of the voice of conscience and doing what is right.
让我解释一下。因此，根据弗洛伊德的理论，人类心灵有三个核心要素。本我（id）、自我（ego）和超我（super-ego）。所以自我（ego）是我们现在的样子。它是我们所表达的行为所创造的现实。而超我和本我，它们有点像你肩膀上的恶魔和天使。超我代表纯粹的道德以及社会期望我们做的事情。超我属于无意识思维或心灵的一部分，它有点像是良知的声音以及做正确的事情。
And there's also the source of self-criticism. In contrast, this is sneaky. little id is the primitive, instinctive component of your personality. It's where intrusive thoughts come from. It contains like our urges, our impulses, and it's where Freud argues, our immediate reactions are born. So then we arrive at the ego, and the ego is the part of your mind that cares about what others think. And it is kind of involved in that balancing act between our pure morals that have been conditioned into us by society and then what we really want to do. And it's what the ego is what we are aware of when we think about ourselves and it's what we
这也是自我批判的源泉。相比之下，这个狡猾的小本我，是你个性中原始、本能的部分。它是侵入性想法的来源。它包含我们的欲望、冲动，弗洛伊德认为，我们的即时反应就诞生于此。然后我们来到了自我，自我也就是你大脑中关心别人怎么想的那一部分。它参与了我们被社会灌输的纯粹道德与我们真正想做的事情之间的这种平衡行为。这就是自我，当我们思考自己时我们所意识到的东西，也是我们通常试图向他人投射的东西。
usually try to project towards others. So this is where people pleasing behaviors come from. It comes from the part of our brain or our mind that recognizes that we can be perceived by others and wants people to like what they see because of that. because of that recognition of perception, we strive to make others happy. And when our ego doesn't strike the balance or the correct balance between the super ego and the id, the side of us that makes it hard to say no and seeks excessive validation, obsessively from others, obsessively from others, yes, that's the part that kind of rores its head. And like I said, perfectionism, it's a pretty core aspect linked to people pleasing. But there is another aspect that's
所以这就是讨好型人格行为的来源。它源于我们大脑或心灵的那一部分，它认识到我们可以被他人感知，并希望人们因为这种认知的认识而喜欢他们所看到的，我们努力让别人开心。当我们的自我没有在超我和本我之间取得平衡或正确的平衡时，也就是让我们难以说“不”并痴迷地向他人寻求过度认可的那一面，痴迷地向他人寻求认可，是的，这就是那部分开始抬头的时候。正如我所说，完美主义是与讨好型人格紧密相连的一个核心方面。但还有另一个方面在那些更关心取悦他人的人当中超级常见，
super common amongst those of us who are more concerned with making others happy. And it's called sociotrophy. Socio-trophy is the tendency to place an inordinate value on our relationships over personal independence. So it's in direct contrast to, I guess, excessive independence or autonomy, which is a concern with personal achievement and control over your daily life rather than what other people think of you. So people with this trait, socio-trophy, tend to have strong needs for social acceptance, which is what causes them to be overly nurturant towards people who they may not even have a close relationship with
它被称为社交倾向（sociotrophy）。社交倾向是指相比于个人独立性，将人际关系赋予过高价值的倾向。因此它与过度独立或自主性形成鲜明对照，后者关注的是个人成就和对日常生活的控制，而不是别人对你有什么看法。所以具有这种特质（社交倾向）的人，往往对社会接纳有着强烈的需求，这导致他们对甚至可能与他们没有密切关系的人，或者他们甚至可能不喜欢的人，表现出过度的关怀。我们可以从一个非常基础的角度真正看出，为什么这样一种人格特质会使你更容易倾向于讨好型人格，以及为了迎合他人而表现出的那种持续的顺从。
or people they might not even like. And we can really see from kind of a very basic viewpoint why a personality trait such as this would make you more predisposed to people pleasing and that constant kind of agreeableness for the sake of others. whilst not specifically linked to people pleasing but something interesting nonetheless is understanding this character trait so people with sociotrophy they also tend to react really differently than those low on this trait in situations that involve self-control so in one experiment
虽然与讨好型人格没有直接联系，但理解这一性格特质依然很有趣：在涉及自我控制的情境中，具有社交倾向的人的反应，往往也与该特质得分较低的人截然不同。所以在其中一个实验中，
they had people who were rated high on the trait of sociotrophy share a meal with another person who was actually an actor and this actor was instructed to either over-eat, under-eat or not eat at all. Sociotropic individuals in this experiment, they consume more food or they try and match appears eating habits when they believe that doing so will make that person, the actor, feel more comfortable. And this is often hypothesized as being the result of the individual attempting to achieve social approval and avoid social rejection. The social pressure and dependence can cause a loss of self-control in an individual, especially if they are unaware of their desire for social acceptance. Now, crucially, sociotrophy has been correlated with feminine or female sex role orientations
他们让在社交倾向特质上得分较高的人与另一个人共享一餐，后者其实是一位演员，而这位演员被指示要么吃得过多、要么吃得过少、要么干脆不吃。在这项实验中，具有社交倾向的个人会消耗更多食物，或者当他们相信这样做能让对方（即那位演员）感到更舒适时，他们会试图迎合对方的饮食习惯。人们通常假设，这是个人试图获得社会认可并避免社会拒绝的结果。这种社会压力和依赖会导致个人失去自我控制，尤其是当他们没有意识到自己对社会接纳的渴望时。现在，至关重要的是，社交倾向在许多研究实验中被反复证实与女性的性别角色取向呈正相关。
in many research experiments again and again. And naturally, the prevalence of people-pleasing behaviours show a similar correlation. So people-pleasing is more commonly presented in women over men, which I think we could probably have assumed. One recent study found this behaviour to be exhibited in the majority of female participants, 59%, whilst only a minority of men, I think around 38%, showed similar tendencies. As a result, women are suffering from greater adverse effects on both their mental and physical health from these behaviours. The pressure that women feel to be people-pleases is very very,
自然地，讨好型人格行为的普遍性也表现出类似的相关性。因此，讨好型人格在女性中比在男性中更常见，我想我们大概也能猜到这一点。最近的一项研究发现，大多数女性参与者（59%）都表现出这种行为，而只有少数男性（大约 38%）表现出类似倾向。因此，女性正在因为这些行为而在身心健康方面遭受更大的负面影响。女性感受到的要成为讨好型人格者的压力是非常非常真实的，它源于围绕女性行为及其在社会中角色的许多历史规范。
real and it comes from a lot of historical norms around female behaviour and their role in society. Women are conditioned really early to be caregivers and more generous with their time and energy because of their, you know, expectant future role as mothers. Even if you don't have children, you see how other women in society act and the amount of sacrifices they're asked to make compared to their male counterparts. And a lot of these sacrifices and, are tied to people pleasing behaviours. This is entirely anecdotal, but a lot of my female friends, they struggle saying no. They struggle establishing boundaries at work with partners and their friends, never having free
由于她们（预期中）未来作为母亲的角色，女性从小就被培养成照顾者，并在时间和精力上更加慷慨。即使你没有孩子，你也能看到社会中其他女性的行为，以及与她们的男性同伴相比，她们被要求做出多少牺牲。而许多这样的牺牲都与讨好型人格的行为息息相关。这完全是个人经验，但我很多女性朋友都很难说“不”。她们很难在工作、伴侣和朋友之间建立界限，从来没有空闲时间，因为她们总是有事情要做，或者是和别人一起做，或者是为别人做。我并不是说这是一个纯粹由性别决定的问题，但研究不会说谎。你知道的，这是一个男人的世界。
time because they always have things to do with or for other people. And I'm not saying it's a purely gendered thing, but the research doesn't lie. You know, it's a man's world. Women are just holding it up without people pleasing behaviors. people pleasing behaviors as we've kind of mentioned they often lead to people taking advantage of you which is why our 20s are such a formative year for setting those boundaries and putting ourselves first some people are really good specifically sociopaths and narcissists they're really good at recognizing and taking advantage of people who display people pleasing tendencies they may not be
没有讨好型人格行为的女性，正苦苦支撑着这个世界。正如我们刚才所提到的，讨好型人格的行为往往会导致别人占你便宜，这就是为什么我们二十岁时是建立这些界限并将自己放在首位的如此关键的时期。有些人真的很擅长，特别是反社会者和自恋者，他们非常擅长识别和利用那些表现出讨好型人格倾向的人。他们可能说不出这种行为的学名，但他们知道你会同意他们提出的任何要求，所以他们会一直要求，而你也会一直说“好”，因为你想让他们开心。这可能会使你面临更高的被操纵、精神或情感虐待的风险，如果有人向你寻求金钱援助，甚至会带来财务问题。
able to name their behavior but they do know that you'll agree to whatever they ask, so they'll keep on asking and you keep saying yes because you want to keep them happy. And this can put you at higher risk of, you know, manipulation or mental or emotional abuse, even financial problems if people ask you for, you know, monetary assistance. We've talked about this a bit as well, but it can also be a real challenge to establishing healthy long-term relationships. Healthy, strong, especially romantic relationships, they're balanced and they involve, give and take. you do nice things for your loved ones and they do the same for you.
我们之前也讨论过这一点，但这也是建立健康的长期关系的一大挑战。健康、强大、尤其是浪漫的关系，它们是平衡的，并且包含付出与回报。你为你的爱人做美好的事情，他们也会为你做同样的事情。当你觉得别人只有在你为他们做了过多的好事情时才会喜欢你时，你可能不会拥有非常充实的浪漫关系。affection（温情），它不是一种商品。当你所做的一切只是为了向他人付出，将自己表现为你认为他们希望看到的人时，你并没有以真实的自我出现在这段关系中。
You probably won't have very fulfilling romantic relationships when you feel like people will only like you if you do nice, excessive things for them. Affection, it's not a commodity. When all you do is give to others to present yourself as the person you think they want, you're not showing up in the relationship as yourself. And it's difficult to maintain, much less feel satisfied with when you aren't actually present in your relationship. Also, I'm super, super sorry if you've had to learn this the hard way, but giving everything to other people, especially a partner or someone you love thinking it will
而且，当你并没有真正“身处”这段关系中时，你很难去维持它，更不用说对它感到满意了。另外，如果为了让别人爱你而把一切都付诸东流，尤其是对一个伴侣或你爱的人，为他们做事，竭尽全力地去不断迎合他们，教他们东西，给他们买东西，任由他们践踏你，却永远无法说服他们更爱你，对此我感到非常非常抱歉。我知道，这可能正是浪漫关系中某些讨好型人格行为的根源所在，因为你认为，如果你付出更多，为他们的幸福做出更多牺牲，你就会成为一个他们离开你就无法活下去的人。他们会回心转意，认识到你是多么了不起。然而事实却永远不会如此。我一次又一次地吸取了教训。
make them love you, doing things for them, going out of your way to constantly serve them, teaching them things, buying them things, letting them walk all over you will never convince them to love you more. And I know that can be where some of these people pleasing behaviors in romantic relationships can come from because you think that if you think that if you're you give more and sacrifice more for their happiness, you'll become someone they can't live without. They'll turn around, they'll recognize how amazing you are. And it's just never going to be the case. I've learnt this time and time again.
情况从未改变。要么他们没有意识到，要么我猜他们只是觉得你喜欢这么做。我知道，这一切看起来并不怎么美好。那么我们该如何改变它，在这些讨好型人格的倾向中不再阻碍自己呢？首先，在你是真心实意时再表达善意。练习善良是完全没有问题的，甚至对你的心理健康来说是一件非常棒的事情。但善良并非源于赢得认可的渴望，它通常不包含任何除了想让别人的情况变得更好之外的动机。
It never changes. Either they don't recognize it or they just assume that you like doing it, I guess. None of this is looking particularly pretty, I know. So how do we change it and get out of our own way with these people-pleasing tendencies? Firstly, show kindness when you mean it. It's perfectly fine and even a really good thing for your mental health to practice kindness. But kindness, it doesn't come from a desire to earn approval and it generally doesn't involve any motive beyond wanting to make things better for someone else.
在你提供赞美之词或帮助之前，请考虑你的动机以及这种行为会带给你什么感受。帮助别人的机会能给你带来快乐，还是你认为这会让你感到怨恨或觉得自己被感激？练习把你自己放在首位。你需要精力和情感资源来帮助别人。如果你不照顾好自己，你将无法或没有能力在未来为其他人做任何事情。把你的需求放在首位并不自私。这实际上相当健康。你知道的，做一个给予他人、充满关怀的人是可以的，但尊重并照顾我们自己的需求同样重要。
Before you offer, you know, words of affirmation or help, consider your intentions and how that act will make you feel. Does the opportunity to help someone else bring you joy or do you think it's going to make you resentful or you're going to feel? appreciated. Practice putting yourself first. You need energy and emotional resources to help others. And if you don't take care of yourself, you won't be able or capable of doing anything for anyone else in the future. Putting your needs first isn't selfish. It's actually quite healthy. You know, it's okay to be a giving caring person, but it's also important to honor and tend to our
请记住，需求可以包括诸如在工作会议上提出你的意见、适应你的情绪和感受以及在你的关系中表达你的需求等事情，这样做有时往往利大于弊，为你自己挺身而出——不仅对你自己更有利，而且如果周围的人知道你的立场，对他们也更有利。我们已经说过很多次了，但要学会设定界限。因此，据心理学家迈尔斯所说，培养健康的界限是克服讨好型人格行为以及建立任何健康的长期关系非常重要的一步。下次当别人寻求帮助或者你很想插手时，
own needs. Keep in mind that needs can involve things like offering your opinion in a work meeting, getting comfortable with your emotions and feelings and asking for what you need in your relationship, that can sometimes do more good than bad, speaking up for yourself and not just more good for yourself, but more good for those around you if they know where you stand. We've said it again and again, but learn to set boundaries. So according to this psychologist, Myers, developing healthy boundaries is a pretty important step, not just in overcoming people-pleasing behaviors, but for setting up any kind of healthy long-term relationship. The next time someone asks for help or you're tempted to intervene,
考虑三件事。你对这个行为有什么感觉？这是你想做的事，还是你对此感到恐惧？你总是可以说不，你总是可以退缩。你除了对自己之外，不欠任何人你的时间和精力。考虑一下你是否有时间首先满足你自己的需求。为了帮助这个人，你是否必须牺牲自己的时间、必要的家务，或者你期待的事情。
consider three things. How do you feel about the action? Is it something you want to do or are you dreading it? You can always just say no, you can always back out. You don't owe your time or your energy to anyone but yourself. Think about whether you have time to cede your own needs first. Will you have to sacrifice your own time or a necessary chore? or something you're looking forward to to helping this other person.
以及提供帮助会让你感觉如何？这会让你感到快乐，还是会让你感到怨恨？最后，等到别人向你求助时再行动。无论问题是什么，你知道的，如果你是一个讨好型人格者，你总是随时准备好解决方案。你在工作中主动承担任务。当朋友提及任何类型的问题时，你会急于给出建议，并主动提出提供帮助。
And how will helping make you feel? Will it make you feel happy or will it make you feel resentful? Finally, wait until you are asked for help. No matter what the problem is, you know, if you're a people pleaser, you're always ready with a solution. You volunteer for things of work. You jump in with suggestions when a friend, you know, mentions any kind of problem offer to help them out.
下一次，挑战自己，等到别人明确向你的请求帮助时再行动。如果你的伴侣，我不知道，开始抱怨他们的老板有多糟糕或者他们的朋友之一有多烂，通过倾听来表达你有多在乎，而不是列出一堆应对这种情况的建议，或者主动去做一些他们甚至可能不需要你做的事情。相比于在财务、个人时间以及其他许多有限资源上付出巨大代价，他们可能更需要同理心和认可。我希望你喜欢这一集更简短的节目。我正试图养成一种习惯，即改变节目的时长，比如更短、更长。这简直就是我刚才说的。但你明白我的意思，只是为了增加一点多样性，
Next time, challenge yourself to wait until someone explicitly asks you for help. If your partner, I don't know, goes off on a rant about how awful their boss is or how shitty one of their friends is, show how much you care by listening instead of, you know, listing off tips to deal with the situation or offering to do something that they might not even need you to do. They may want empathy and just validation more than anything else and probably involves a lot less from you financially, personally, in terms of your time and a lot of other limited resources. I hope you enjoyed this more bite-sized episode. I'm trying to get into the habit of kind of varying how long the episodes are, like shorter, longer. That's literally what I just said. But you get my gist just so that there's a bit of variety
这样你就不必坐着听一整段 50 分钟的、关于你可能根本不在乎的事情的废话了。说重点，杰玛，我懂的。下周我们要聊聊爱的语言。我和朋友们讨论这个话题已经好几年了。我开始思考它们是否有效，它们是否真的是评估你在一段关系中真正需要什么的可靠工具。我们最近做了很多基于关系的播客。我刚刚也意识到了这一点。
and you don't have to sit back and listen to some 50-minute ramble about things you might not even care about. Get to the point, Gemma, I understand. Next week we're going to talk about love languages. I have been discussing this with my friends for years. And I kind of started to think whether they're valid, whether they're actually a reliable tool for assessing what you need in a relationship. We're doing a lot of relationship-based podcasts at the moment. I also just realized that recently as well.
我不知道。我最近只是真的很迷恋社会心理学。它实在太迷人了，也非常有趣。因此你会看到你的信息流中出现更多以人为本的节目。如果你不喜欢，没关系。更多积极心理学和生物心理学的内容很快就会回归。但这期播客是关于你的二十岁以及我们在二十岁时建立的人际关系，我认为这可能是最重要的方面之一。另外，我在每一集里都会说这个，但如果你坚持听到了这里，请如果你愿意的话，如果你有多余的五秒钟，真的，五秒钟，十秒钟，在 Spotify 或 Apple 播客上给这个播客留个评价。但如果你不想做，如果你认为这会强化任何讨好型人格的倾向，那就别做。你知道的，设定好那些界限。你什么都不欠我。不过这会非常nice。
I don't know. I'm just really into the social psychology at the moment. It's just really quite tantalizing and very interesting. Hence why you're seeing a lot more of those people-focused episodes on your feed. If you don't like it, that's okay. More of the positivism and more of the biological psychology is coming back soon. But this is a podcast about your 20s and the relationships we form in our 20s are, I think, probably one of the most important aspects. Also, I say this every episode, but if you have made it this far, please, if you feel inclined, if you have a few extra five seconds, really, five seconds, 10 seconds, leave the podcast.
谢谢你们的收听。感谢一如既往地支持本播客。如果你有什么真正希望我研究的想法，请在网站上或 Instagram 上留言。目前我做研究的乐趣似乎比录制节目的乐趣还要大。我把所有这些精彩的论文都保存在我的浏览器里，我正努力看完它们，
review on either Spotify or Apple podcasts. But if you don't want to do it, if you think that that's going to reinforce any people-pleasing tendencies, don't do it. You know, set those boundaries. You don't owe me anything. But it would be very nice.
以便让这些内容像以往一样基于实证。所以是的，如果还有什么你想加到那个堆里的东西，请随时告诉我。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，祝你度过一个美妙的周末，感谢收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
And thank you for listening. Thanks for supporting the podcast as always. Drop a line on the website or on Instagram if you have any ideas that you really want me to kind of look into. I love doing the research kind of more than I like recording in the episodes at the moment. I've got all of these like amazing papers saved in my browser that I'm just trying to get through
即在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWA percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。来自 1979 年，对那时的我来说是一个重大时刻。84 年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的，
to make these kind of as evidence based as they have typically been. So yeah, if there's anything else you want to add to that pile, please feel free to do so and have an amazing weekend wherever you are in the world and thank you for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。在此之前，那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家最近怎么样？
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it,
你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、Apple podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 learn the hard way。这是一个 iHeart 播客。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。在那之前，那是一个疯狂的年份。那真的是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回首往事”（Look Back at It）。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's. experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the iHeart radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an iHeart podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您正在收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kier Games）为您带来的《用惨痛教训学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉极不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，您是在与一位知晓如何应对的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男性穿着西装就像穿着盔甲一样？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《用惨痛教训学习》。这是一档iHeart播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。